reading some podcasts village Thursday
the 24th of [__] October the
church is brought to you by
manscape listen it's Halloween you want
to get your dick sucked
how can you get your dick sucked when
your dick looks like [__] Eddie
Munster you don't need that in your life
all right uncle Joey's here to tell you
Halloween
keep the [__] cobwebs out of your
pants all right my friends over at
manscape created a tool you need to
shave your balls in the area around it's
called a lawn mower 2.0 [__]
tremendous it does not Nick or snag your
sack no [__] anxiety no nothing plus
it's perfect for travel and easy to
charge you can manscape wherever you go
I do it one [__] handed as you'll see
on Paris on Instagram Monday morning I
shaved my nuts in the toilet you're not
gonna see my nuts it's not rated X it's
just straight up [__] head a little
Pew beer anyway manscape will get your
slung looking [__] nice and shiny and
this is the first time you consider a
manscaping they got to deal for you it's
called the perfect package but for right
now listeners from the church can get
20% off your first order when you use
promo code church at manscape calm and
if you order the perfect package don't
also throw in a free travel bag when you
use promo code Church CH you are CH that
travel bag consists of the crop
preserver the Reviver and a beautiful
razor called the plow it's you're gonna
[__] love it alright just hear me out
here church family go to manscape calm
preston church get 20% off your first
order
that's manscape calm keep your mother
[__] balls clean the church is also
brought to you by my bookie that said
it's over [__] world series is here
pro basketball is [__] here
the Lakers lost on Tuesday night at home
everybody ate a bag of dicks on [__]
Tuesday night the line went from minus 1
to plus 3.5 that it was amazing they
just destroyed you they just [__]
destroyed and you know the good thing is
you could you could have been part of
that but you weren't
attention you were somewhere else
jumping up and down talking about going
to the weave cafe like a [__] Momo
football season to you
all right basketball season two here the
World Series is here you like winning
money you want to keep walking around
with rabbit ears coming out of your
[__] pocket you're like betting
sports well I'll tell you want to put
your money down my bookie doll Agee
that's where if you're trying to bet on
the NFL baseball MMA whatever the [__]
my bookies got it right now they're
running a super contest a hundred to get
in you pick five teams against the
spread listen you're racking up points
first place $100,000 guaranteed
where you gonna pick that up on February
3rd nowhere my bookie dot AG that's what
they got going on so do me a favor right
right now today let's start the weekend
off on the right [__] foot I'm
feeling a little [__] lucky so you
it's Thursday right you're waking up
you're saying you know what today
they're gonna suck my dick right now you
go to my bookie down AG double your
first deposit right now use promo code
Church grab a pen CH you are CH to get
100% bonus on your initial deposit up to
a hundred thousand up to a thousand
dollars now who could do that for you on
a [__] Thursday nobody visit my
booking dot AG today that's my bookie
dot AG today don't forget to use promo
code Church when creating your account o
real quick right now do me a favor you
started looking yourself in the mirror
you going [__] I'm losing hair the last
time you get your girlfriend a stabbing
in the middle of the stab and your
little star mean get got soft you know
you don't need this aggravation
I mean 66% of men stuff to lose the hand
by the age of 35 do you want a bald spot
to pop up and your hairline to recede or
do you want to do something about it
first I got the answer for hems calm
it's a one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care and sexual wellness for men I'm not
saying that you got limp-dick but what
I'm saying is that's going let's say
you're going on a date you already gave
her a stabbing you missed a couple spots
last time and this time you want to do
it good
you missed a couple yeah you missed a
couple positions you want the tire up by
her feet dude anyway I don't know about
that what I do know is for him calm it's
a one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men what we're
gonna do now is this let's say you
having a problem with your little head
dude
I'm losing hands by the day but I'm 56
it served its purpose but you young
[__] you got no hair are you
gonna sling dick with no hair especially
over the holiday season listen the
church family gets I'm gonna get you
started with a complete hick hair kit
for just five hours you're gonna [__]
Joey five hours five [__] hours what
am I gonna go in Mexico no this gets a
little bit right to your [__] house
all right this is for hims calm right
now while supplies last I'm gonna get
your files for the first month Hey
subject the doctors approved all right
you got to see the website for full
details of the safety information I
don't want you saying Joey I'm over here
sitting bald all of a sudden I'm growing
hair I'm a [__] beetle whatever
listen if you went to a doctor you'd
spend [__] thousands or a pharmacy
somewhere you spent hundreds I'm gonna
save you all that aggravation no
doctor's visit gonna go to four hens
calm slash Joey right now for hims calm
slash Joey Lee kick this [__] meal I
love it it's a beautiful [__] day to
be alive [__] what it is that is
a bad way to start a day this endless is
Billy Ray Billy Wayne we don't let them
say whatever state the [__] sea it's
good to see you too it's been a long
time a nice time I saw you were a young
man just that's fair yes young man yeah
kind of fatter and drunker how long you
don't come before now 16 years when did
I meet you you met me [__] so 2006 West
Palm Beach you started in 2000 I started
around 2002 2003 West Palm Beach with
Ralphie
no I wasn't what no it was through
Ralphie I was down there I had met my
now ex-wife down there
we I was hanging out with her and you
and Joe came to the improv and he was
like yo you need to go meet uncle Joey
and I didn't have you know [__] feet
track so if I had $50 on me I was like
we are doing good
so yeah that's when I met you you were
super nice like one of the funniest
people had ever seen it's like one of
those things where I was like oh oh I
gotta rethink how I'm doing a lot of
this it was just to watch you do this
and then I got nervous and then you were
really nice and then that's just an
intense place to meet anyone so now you
with the Spanish girl at the time yes
okay yes you met her down there yes and
then I joined up in Seattle she got a
job there okay no double months after I
met yeah you do the radio together which
you know listen I got great I could tell
you what I ate for breakfast lady to ask
already for breakfast and no [__] idea
I don't think maybe y'all did yeah you
probably did the joe in West Palm
cuz she was on the radio list on that
main radio yes Oh without a doubt yeah
because that's how I met her when you
started well in Nashville Tennessee is a
no [__] open mic and it the whole [__]
yes yeah it was yeah Nashville I was
spoiled because Nazi knees is where I
started I got to be the house MC there
for a while and then I served it out in
the road and that place is so perfect
for stand-up they treat you so well it's
the best people come through there then
when I went out on the road I was like
what the [__] is this
so there's a comedy club I was like no
it's not there's not even in your eye
okay I need to shut up you know like I
just need to be thankful for work but I
was so spoiled about how it could be and
now I've been doing it 16 years and my
oh that's still the best place and you'd
be the house and see Sunday through yeah
it would be Wednesday through Sunday
usually oh yes you get good quick oh
yeah you get really there was like a
local open mic on Tuesdays and then but
like I was so used to because I just I
quit college
well after I started doing stand-up
because I was like oh this is what I
want to do and so I was ready to respect
somebody is did you throw away in
college decided
this is a polite there's a question I
ask a lot of people I would say I threw
away two years and then I played
baseball for the first two years
scholarship you could call it no and
don't disrespect that I didn't mean
they'll throw it away what I mean was I
think what I mean was finding ourselves
oh yeah you know I'm a big debate I run
and now I have a daughter and I'm still
thinking about it
wait they want it the first year of
college take off go get a job yes
learn just what the outside world is
learning a little bit and then go to
college and now you'll have more of an
idea it's like I tell people that are
doing stand-ups and then they get into a
movie yeah yeah when people do a movie
they excited for the first three days
[__] I mean like a king after the tenth
week that 14-hour days you're like I
can't wait to get back on the road and
make $600 yes and do whatever I want to
[__] my time you know it takes somebody
to be you know the grass is always
[__] arena when you're in Clark
Tennessee on a one night of the creative
yeah and you're like my life has to
change
yeah and then you come back in your book
a TV show for three weeks you know like
wow I'm on TV [__] Clark Tennessee and
I'm can you ever do that can't do that
it's so weird
out even now like when I'm a little
bored would stand up like this year I
got a movie I was a little burnt out at
the time I'm not gonna lie to it
well you at the end of a run period is
different than you at the beginning of a
run just think of the flight to the gig
on Wednesday Thursday and in that flight
home Saturday Sunday morning just how
you feel at then and like that's how he
would jump with a gun here well how
about the drive on Tuesday night that's
what I said but you know what I may then
drive Sunday at 9:00 o'clock with your
car pack when the club gives you that
last cheeseburger then you breathe the
same same burgers Wednesdays it's
consistent it's consistent and they give
you one to go at nights you wake up in
the middle of my tea the [__]
cheeseburger man you know that that I
don't know I but do you think at that I
think and I got this we were talking
earlier before he's like certain gifts
that
you at the time you're like man this is
devastating but like five years into the
future you see something like that
coming and then you get out of the way
like oh that's why oh oh I'm so glad
that hit me when I didn't have anything
that kind of stuff right so like I
remember this guy I started with who I
still is one of the funniest people I
know but doesn't he hated everything I
loved about the road immediately like
being away from home being in shitty
hotels seeing a new shitty town like
meeting terrible people I loved every
second of it and then getting on stage I
was like oh [__] it oh and we get to do
stand-up this is he hated every part of
it and then he had a regular job by the
end of the year cuz he was like this is
not and he's still doing stand-up for
that no no no it just wasn't for he
recognized that early like this is what
this is for a long time and I hate all
this stuff okay you get into stand-up
yeah you get into plumbing you get into
construction and get into whatever
you're in part of a union you work in a
day time and three nights a week you go
for classes and all sudden three years
and you meet a [__] girl yep and you
spit out a [__] kid and now your life
has to change a different point you have
to start sacrificing a little that's
like football league you win on
Saturdays that's out the window count
you go to your to Lee's house to watch
football on Sunday that's done you know
there's all these things that get
eliminated you know with comedy it's so
weird how even for me I tell this to
people all the time one minute it's 6:15
and I'm sitting across the table staring
my six-year-old same prayers before
breakfast knowing that two hours later
I'm gonna go to the store and talk about
Nancy Pelosi's titties oh yeah it is
that the younam's I am yeah that's a
distinct difference when we he is friend
in like but it is the same thing is like
some people don't
I told number four well I suppose
I learned there was 50 guys to comedy
scene was great roseann boy just come
out of that yeah so the cops do great in
jail it's still great in Denver
there were comics that went on the road
there were comics to help our
aspirations of TV mm-hmm and I could
name you three Thomas right now that
decided the road wasn't gonna have that
accepted that yeah bad kids they had
wives didn't believe in sleeping in a
sleazy hotel or paying their dues and
they wrote a lot that became good
writers it forces you to do different
things yes yes it's a different thing
it's me cutting off your left arm yeah
you can't go out on the road no if
you're left on are you gonna make it
through life now and this guy ended up
being like a headliner
a Denver headliner and at that time
Denver had four clubs Colorado Springs
at four o'clock from 101 Club that's
five club that's five clubs that's ten
weeks at once Tanner that's 15 on
$15,000 whatever he would do all the
one-niners in the area he would do the
New Year's at a local bar and whatever
I'd see him I give him a hug and he was
[__] happy and [__] yeah and I used to
look at him at that time and go between
us what a loser
now he knew but he wasn't a loser no I
respected him because he knew what he
was gonna become this is what I don't
like about this and I'm not doing it
yeah I'm not don't freedom it's it's a
freedom I'm not doing it and but how is
if if this is really your dream to paint
and you don't like going over the 10th
floor of a warehouse you know you have
to figure out how to paint yeah exactly
okay you have to figure out how to do
what you're doing and become successful
make a living
I've sent this once and I've said
there's 10,000 times I'll stand behind
it this 50 guys scattered in each state
how many states we got 50 50 50 who's
got 50 right now ft3
50 54 with Mexico I'm saying
yes 52 there's 52 comics that are
funnier than 10 people are going to
Comedy Store right now
Oh without a doubt that are stuck in
that situation they're scared they're
married with kids but they can outright
outperform outdance I'll [__] do
anything my [__] fat ass and half the
[__] Congress in that way here's what
though here's the question I have when
I've done this - I agree with you but
fear is it's that extra thing that makes
you go to the Comedy Store or makes you
move your family out and live in the
valley while you go do this and then
find other avenues to make money being
creative that those guys are like I like
knowing that I'm this good but that
extra thing that they can't go on the
road if it pops do you know what I mean
or they're scared if it pops because
what if a lot of people know who I am
that's a scary one for me for a while
was people knowing who I am and then
what if they come see me and I'm not
funny I got over it you know once you
see how much money you make
oh that's even better but that's I just
think that it's okay I look at it
through the eyes the lens of like a
baseball player like I saw I got to a
certain point that I was like oh this is
what it needs to be done to be a
professional and play it the thing I
thought I won I have no [__] interest
in that was it that was mentally
devastating for me I didn't realize it
at the time but it was just something it
was very obvious like oh I want to do
this anymore
this is not what I thought it was but I
can still exist in a certain level
that's respectable in baseball but I it
wasn't that I couldn't where I didn't
want to go do this that this made me
happy it was like oh I don't have the
mental capacity to play baseball you
obviously thought that what we're
talking about yeah I well the question I
have is
like at a certain point it seems like
because I know for me my goal for a lot
of my life was just money yeah you know
that I mean for the people who are stuck
and for the people who like I you got to
a place where like I don't want to do I
don't want to deal with the bus rides to
the baseball games I don't want to deal
with with it with the ten hour workout
so whatever it was that maybe you not
want to do it it's not that like is it
that is it weird to like make what you
love into a business at a certain point
like no all right no I think about I
think looking back on it if I could a
skip some steps there's a point you get
to a professional level where it's
probably like relaxing that it's in a
baseball level or you're just like well
I'm a whatever and it's this performance
so there's only so much I can you know
you're a commodity so when you quit
college you pretty basic with baseball
no I quit baseball before a clear call
okay so when you quit baseball how did
you feel our leaf or were you in the
back of your mind did you see yourself
playing for the Yankees did you see
yourself on the mound last night against
the [__] I always okay to a point
yeah how did it feel when you saw them
done did you feel
I knew it needed to be done like when I
went to the bigger school I knew people
on the team that asked me if I was
interested in coming to like what tryout
or whatever and like I was like you know
there was a good day where I was like
huh and I was like no I don't I don't I
want to see what all this other stuff is
about because the thing looking back the
thing I hated the most about it was it's
every day I had to play baseball every
day of all year and I grew up playing
every sport whatever was in season and
you know I also like my mom's an English
teacher my dad's a history teacher and a
football coach so I have like this
academic side - that was [__] pounded
into me so I have all these other
interests and I was like this just
doesn't see and people are on steroids
so I was like now this isn't the thing I
thought no it was a comedy bug hawai
when you at this point
I mean as an interest yeah but not as a
performer you haven't got up yet
no I was just falling at parties okay do
you know what I mean like I had to like
be funny I was like the final push
before you go on stage this girl I was
dating said why don't you try it cuz I
always watched it like always kind of
obsessive about like funny stuff a lot
of the days who are you watching that's
a comic who do you remember I remember
this is like a thrill of mine was like I
worked in the computer part of the
campus that there was my on-campus job I
was just someone that installed him
because I knew shapes you know you just
plug in shapes so the none of the
software [__] out do it but look he's
strong in those shapes but then they
this guy that knew the computers taught
me Napster and I found Hedberg because I
went straight everybody else is like
music and I won't strike to stand up now
that looked back oh that's like the
first thing I did and I never heard of
him but he was a very popular on the
underground thing I was like I start
listen to him is that first one from the
laughs stop and I was like this is he
was my secret for a while he said this
is some funny [__] ever heard and then I
missed your show I was like I was really
into that at the time and I like
Gaffigan in the tail and I love greg
Giraldo
so when i got to meet some of these
people later it was like shouldn't I
played it real cool with both of Mitch
and Greg I got to hang with them but it
was like well they didn't let me down
either they were just like real last
dudes and that's probably why I dug them
so much looking back on it but that's
who I was into I mean Bill Hicks when I
first started comedy I didn't know who
he was if I'm being honest until you
meet other oppa my kids were like have
you heard this dude that's great
then she pursued she she told me she was
like just go try it
where'd you go Sammy's no she's in
Bowling Green Kentucky and Zanies was
the closest thing I knew of a stand-up
Club they had a night in Bowling Green
like once a month I remember I found out
Tom so both the Louisville booked it you
know I found out later all what all of
it was but before
you're just like there's a thing they do
kind of and I never went there
sober enough to really before I was
interested in it to understand what it
was there's like some dude talking in
the other room my weed there's a shot
special
so yeah that's what was it quick so you
got up is a nice for the first time yeah
you had to call the lady was mean that I
was called she was like I'm a I remember
she said cocked in the phone call I
remember being like this is different
there's like any other business you
called if they said Connor anything like
that
I'll just member like this is cool so
you had to bring four people but they
had a lineup it like 15 people there I
got four or five minutes and they all
brought four people so it was like once
a week he was packed to an open lake
yeah Wow it was packed but the guy they
went on before me was [__] so bad and
I just spoke in front of people enough
to like church and baseball and all that
stuff it was like I can talk and then I
got laugh and I think the audience was
like this guy's like he gets what this
is so there was like that relief and I
did all right I mean some of it didn't
go the way I wanted it to but overall I
was like I remember being relieved on
stage that I had found what I was gonna
do with my life like that moment like
conscious is really a weirdest [__]
[__] insane I mean I'm the law you
know when your own like the tenth step
you like that's it I still remember 1991
walking up the hill at little hill at
comedy versus I got onstage at Comedy
Works 8 that's we're both spoiled and
this is the pinnacle how is roofing I
was going to estimator school I was
thinking like going back to college and
trying to get finished my degree like in
Fort Collins but lost everything went
down the tube right after that I walked
up the comedy club owner said that I
have good stage presence to keep coming
back
after the show wrapped they said stick
around and people were talking to you
know was the first time people have
talked to me about anything except
cocaine me now in prison and [__] like
this yeah like I've been to every
conversation I've ever had there's
always a negative one this is like the
first time I'd be born when you ain't
come back you know and all this [__] I'm
just driving home sitting next to my
wife at the time going like oh yeah this
is never gonna happen because you
weren't it was so you felt so good and
that was so [__] foreign to probably
listen guys right now you're in ecology
you're working in the desk office one
night one night you taking a guitar and
you go down to [__] Julio's ball you
get three beers and you go up then you
do a rendition of [__] Joan Baez and
you fall in love with it but you got a
wife and a kid yeah and you got
insurance for the family and now you're
gonna go back to your [__] desk and
add numbers and call white people and
tell them why they should buy your
sanitation products or whatever the [__]
you do for a living yeah and now you
have this passion inside of you it's a
horrible feeling it was like a horrible
and oh and then man I got a gig I came
really rich which really right there the
next night was like are you busy I'm on
it can you do the Denver Bronco training
camp facility tomorrow night Greeley and
I'm like are you [__] serious
so you have to meet the Broncos the the
shitty ones crazy reward amazing and
there was like a headliner to somebody
else I just want to end up like three
minutes I didn't know what I was doing
I'm driving home called oh my god they
gave me finals for cats some when I was
like oh my god but how am I gonna get
hurt how the [__] am I gonna because I
had already worked at a comedy club
before I got onstage I don't have the
ball suit onstage or economic loud like
I was six months so I asked a lot of
questions yeah and everybody told me
about the road and you started $150 a
week under $50 a week is 600 a month I
think and that's yeah and you're driving
there's no helicopter service to get you
to where you're going so now all these
things how did you feel well you weren't
married well that's the thing like I was
at that age where I was like oh I could
only and I had to figure out how to quit
school I think that was the thing right
after that till my parents but they
figured it out pretty quick and then I
was a good enough student it wasn't that
you know what I mean it was that wasn't
the issue and they were looking back
they were just good like yeah we were
wasting [__] money just like kind of
getting drunk and doing fine in school
then I was like that's a good point but
then because of baseball or whatever
discipline I had that same mentality
where I was like oh I went and worked at
a restaurant for a month and just save
that money live my parents for like a
month and a half
that's his I the plan was three months
but I could only do a month and a half
back home I was like and I just took all
that money and lived on this dude's
couch for eight months and got a serving
job and was just at Zanies pour it any
this comedy thing I could be at in
Chattanooga or anything for the next
well now it's pretty much what I started
doing you know then I got married when I
was far enough in when I got married the
first dress up in the co well Ralphie
came through I was working as a knees
and his his feature at the time was not
good at comedy and they dude I I was
hosting as a knees I was supposed to do
12 10 to 15 minutes depending on the
hood act was I did 10 his Ralphie's were
both and I came off and then me and
Ralphie were just talking and the dude
that was featuring just came walking out
walk walking back into the green room
seven minutes after I introduced it
and now he's like what you doing he was
like oh I'm done so I just like ran out
there and I was like now if he's like
give me a minute and so I like stalled
him do the announcements or whatever and
then brought out Ralphie and Ralphie
does his thing and came back and then
just like berated that Duty like what
you're supposed to do at least 2025
minutes he's like why'd you come on he
was like I wasn't doing good and I
remember being like I was in comedy just
long enough to I was like you can't do
that you can't you just gotta like sit
in it for the next [__] till till you
get that light man that's how that works
he was like I was doing bad so as they
get off the stage and I just remember
thinking like as it's a crazy thing to
just say even now if I'm being honest it
is crazy to hear never walked off the
stage never knew you could never knew as
an option though I was just like oh it's
not going good this is gonna hurt okay
good night
you can't no I never need your like I
have to get paid so you guys have to be
mad at me for the next 15 minutes well I
just try to talk he's left and then I
made it rougher for him the rest of the
week because I was young and mean you
know you don't know your job more than
you are competitive so I was like I just
smelled blood and I was like don't make
it real hard for us to and rally thought
that was funny that I was doing that and
then we got along just because he's a
poor kid from Arkansas I was a poor kid
from East Tennessee he was way poorer
than he grew up or not dead but same
kind of outlook about like what are
these all these no these people leave
what's happening let's go
he was like right we lived on i-40 we
lived on the same interstate it's
different persons like we can get out of
here it's [__] great so we got along
on that level and then we smoked weed a
bunch and he asked me to come to
Chattanooga in a couple weeks my sister
lived near that place so I just stayed
in them and then I made it rough for
that dude again and I was doing purpose
I was a good dude is he right
no no I know them berries him but I
dunno I remember his name okay is he
still around I don't know if he does
stand up yeah but he might you know it
might be one of those things really like
he's doing corporate [__] can you just
open oh he's making money and then you
out him somebody hears it to sleep I
doubt he's doing corporate yeah yeah
he's I liked him as a person he just
wasn't good at stand up listen but you
know I told this to a lot of people when
you don't come in two three four years
you're in danger yeah because that's the
first time people see you don't want
nobody say no you don't want nobody is
he you wanna hide like a [__]
I'd only do the creepiest gigs so when
you're ready for that four year gig
you're ready yes but anybody who see you
before the first four years
that's all they remember for five years
I was that that was what I was told for
five years that's what they were gonna
remember the fire if you work like you'd
banging them out and [__] it's four
years you feel it because I yeah I
didn't like like I started to feel it
like I had done it three years spinning
my wheels and three is where I ate slept
and drank it and [__] it that was it
there's no other option to get good at
right well absolutely like two years of
spending or three years of spinning your
wheels the worst thing is to see
somebody jump over oh yeah yeah that's
it always happen yeah it always happens
two or three people that you don't open
mics with now they're regulars at the
Comedy Store you like how the [__] did
whoa okay this is what needs to be done
your whole career yeah yeah now but see
that's well those guys that didn't want
to go on the road everybody has
different phobias I was taught my style
of child he was taught you had to go on
the road and you had to go on the road
and there was a road system yes it's a
room a B room a C room and [__]
you're in hell
you need some work for the first two or
three is you just inhale rowm on zero
that's it you know
to go out every once in a while a friend
years to throw you into a room just to
look just to pull yourself out of the
water they may show the island is still
there well and districts gotta push
yourself that it is good to know what
you're working on what you're working on
yes that was huge for me
and because of think got my work ethic
that helped me to be at Zanies also
seeing this was huge for me looking like
seeing different acts that I'd
necessarily wouldn't give a [__] about
selling out and you were doing 28 shows
a month so no he did a good job of being
like some months would be two weeks okay
some months three some months one
do you know in seven sets oh it was a
Thursday Friday Wednesday to 2001 Suns
in and up three Saturday 3:00 Saturday
yes I learned exactly Saturday that's
the accelerated program oh it was my
friends when I go back to album I could
be like this isn't fair and I'm like no
no it's them out it's not subtle right
there well then see we got tell people
all the time at MC week like once you
get into the MC price especially here
now all right they want to skip it what
darkness thing know how someone told us
it may be harsh don't you do 10 guest
sets at those improv you got 1 2 3 4 up
in Oxnard guess it's a Thursday somebody
talk to you know when you wake up on a
Monday the first thing you should do is
look at the improv
she yeah and see he was doing shows I
see who's producing show and reach I'm
going to do five [__] minutes and
then you do a 5 then somebody else that
produces the show then you do 5 again
then the called manager come up you know
I met you have you ever thought I'm
saying yeah yeah okay call Reid on
Monday and actually no really gives you
to run around for about three months
which you know that's your job and then
boom all of a sudden somebody Falls
David Spade falls out and the whole team
falls out yeah so there you are you're
available you host know she says what
are you doing next week I got a spot
Ontario
and boom and you're going you know
Thursday Friday Saturday and now you get
into the rotation of those unsee spots
and you hate it it's not doing them till
you hate it you know alright let me give
a free glass you know it sucks but all
those pauses and all those going away
from comedy and going back to comedy
that's an education oh my god that's an
education that you don't get an open
mics at all
Brian Dorfman looking out of the other
is a nice and he said there's some
members it's like the second day where I
was like because the first time he
doesn't he's very smart
just once you go out and do your thing
and he's watching second day he's like
all right your job is to get these
announcements right get these guys
credits right and tell them how much
this stuff is and if you're funny that's
[__] cool I don't give a [__] and I
was like pumpka I just remember laughing
because I was a cool I liked him
then I get what there's this gig it's
like all I have to do is these things in
the rest he doesn't care what I'm doing
but other people heard that is like what
the [__] isn't some comedian knows it no
no that's cool he just told me what I
had to do and the rest he said didn't
give a [__] I think he recognized that
the key looking back like he was giving
people tests that I saw other friends of
mine just failed miserably will be like
huh he's giving you this leeway to see
what you're gonna do and you fail that's
why it's not I just like I was thankful
now that I had someone like that early
on cuz like other friends of mine were
just they didn't know what they were
getting into cuz it was like a endurance
test there's like [__] Special Forces
[__] where it's like not what you're
doing the task
it's see if you can mentally get through
this horseshit because that's all this
whole business is is mental horseshit
giving you these in the people that he
may quit or whatever didn't even realize
he's making them quit he gave them gifts
to use like you're gonna waste your time
doing this this is so I just think those
things are really like that's why I I
couldn't just be someone in the middle
of the country do you know what I mean
when you how long do stay in Seattle for
three years too long how was that comedy
scene it's at the time that really
squirts you it was great it was that
what we're talking about earlier where
you're like we just knew the road that's
all we knew
that's all I knew at the time I thought
my god that's all I know so when I got
there I saw these guys I was like cuz
there was a pipeline to LA that I didn't
knew exists right
that's the pipeline into LA and I was
like oh these guys are like jumping down
in this way I didn't know you could do
but also recognize when I got up there
there were different ropes that was the
thing the road did give me that gift
where I'm like oh these are just there's
a ton of different rooms where a lot of
guys if they would stay in their room or
their type of room and I was like no
there's a dunk there you can do your act
in different rooms as it's great there's
a bunch of like a casinos up here
there's rock creams down here there's
college gigs there's corporate gigs
great clubs in the city you know what I
mean you were there with giggles giggles
was it came and went
we don't think it's Vegas right Mormon
guy that he gave it up yeah yeah he gave
it up and the underground and they
burned down or some [__]
the old underground I was there for the
very first year I was there the
underground existed where it was where
you were there right and then they had
to retrofit that building so they moved
it over to that heroine square your
partner Thomas that's where it is now
yeah yeah it's just people go pick up
smack but it's not even I'm not speaking
out of places very much whether it was
they used to be a bar down the bottom
the underground if you walked out of the
underground you walked out of that bar
that was like that little strip mall
right there with Josh Schwartz boy I was
a Mexican blog called Lobo Loco
that's yeah I know you don't know yeah
but it's like build up but that if ya
walked outside the economy underground
and you look to the corner I was a club
owned by heart
they band yes okay Oh from Seattle okay
and they rehearse there and some nights
you'd walk out in here you know crazy
volume
like what the [__] and he is late I was
listening to a radio thing and that's
why Chris Cornell was tight with art no
[__]
yeah they will offer me that [__]
little hairier there okay how crazy I
mean it makes sense to that they were
all on drugs you know I think I think
the colonies toil but the place where I
cut my teeth I mean I learned a lot
about life there too oh yeah God that I
cut my teeth that you know and I was
telling Lee that there's these people
that open up these open mic places in LA
and they charge you five bucks you going
to do five minutes today five minutes
yeah that's funny guy that has no tough
way to make money that's run by I gather
no knowledge of comedy no knowledge of
basically anything he just he's a
businessman and I immediately saw the
car woman Hogan car woman Hogan was the
manager on one day and asked for the
open mic if you remember well tomorrow
yeah he's still kicking car you'd walk
off the stage and he'd be on the phone
like yes show started eight yeah let's
be here 15 minutes before show time
please bring battle ID and he'd look at
you and go like this with his finger and
then they'd hang up the phone and go
commit put this here like he was honest
with you and right and to the T to the T
to the T if everybody had that coming up
from that five to seven year mark again
your ego has to be right to accept that
yes a lot of people go [__] you that's
my favorite joke what do you don't yet
your life there's people like Phil
Jackson Phil Jackson was the worst
basketball player seen in my life but he
won six championships there's certain
people like Mitzi shore certain people
there's certain people I can come up the
end go this get rid of it just put it
here this put in here make this your
opener you want and you're sitting there
going
oh wow yeah why are you opening up with
this then noticing this already what
they're gonna notice you don't need to
hope and would put this in third and
then talk about it he just gave me the
equation and you left and he didn't have
no paper no emotion they don't Moshe I
was there and he was just dropping on
you and you'd walk up the stairs and why
you were walking up you're like [__] but
then you knew you were coming back on
Tuesday yeah
so now you will up there didn't he God
ah okay now at the end of this add this
tag right there and you go how amazed to
have a joke that like you know this is
four year comedy jokes I went to you you
went to my grandmother's house there was
a picture County with an X through it
and my grandma lonely those three words
of English [__] think I know it started
out with something else next time you go
up on stage I want you to say I forget
what the joke was yeah say this
eliminate this but say [__] the
candidates dog it was killing that joke
chill if I got to a lie and he just
thought I got to get rid of it because
like a year old but he just put I had
another joke about a tampon the string
you know you see a girl with a string
and I used to say you don't know what to
pull it on light in the head and nothing
like that one that he gave me that was
about AIDS ribbons that people walk
around with aids you ever see somebody
who got VD walk around with a [__]
pen yeah it was just he would always
take you he taught me to take a joke
from ear to hear it's a joke but he also
was really he and I got along because we
hated overusing words right he taught me
the efficiency of words he and I were
always all learning works for always
like you said they say to me well
goodbye
what's with the sales pitch it's that's
it get rid of it get rid of that but it
set up you know Donny
more fawning and then I discovered that
because I was trying to be a joker oh
yeah if someone tells you how much the
mom water out around tonight tonight I
you see that I used to day that girl I
was crazy I still love her we still talk
from time to time she was crazy she was
just a stripper mm-hmm
Dorothy Lee today cuz she got me tell
away
well there is those tight we need those
type of women when you have that type of
level it's yes father journey yes it is
they're teaching you about what you're
gonna happen yes it's the journey that's
this is what I tell people about the
journey the journey is everything
includes women houses people's house
they sleep at just a couple of things
popped in my head and popped in my head
alone yeah you said that
oh yeah oh yeah and they're special they
called angels yes if you look up on
Facebook you'll not find them if you
look at my body come up on you're not
find them there they're missing they're
angels angels
yeah that would an ago you help you get
from point A to point B because you were
putting so much effort into your comedy
this is how the universe to carry you
yeah by putting that person that
situation that car ride that couch oh
yeah yeah what do you mean you leaving
Monday I got a room that 300 on Tuesday
night that light court battle yeah you
understand how that yes that's gonna
work later we look oh you need to pay
one because this could be it that just
those yes all those things yeah it's
it's a very special call is one of the
people we still talk to like Josh wolf
yeah like I still talk to Carl to Josh
wolf when he goes up there they go to
lunch and stuff I thank him like that's
what I would want to open once I retire
and [__] I definitely love to open up a
coffee shop with comments did Tom and I
sat in the back and I just told you one
time like that's why I loved about Carl
well that's all you need card just no no
no car use of telling me this [__]
bum like Carl was the king of that like
this guy bombs everything cuz he won't
wasn't come okay don't listen to me you
don't meanwhile I guess at the county
underground you gotta start number one
yes and then you move up the list of
father you get and he goes he was number
three when you got here
now you're number nine and he's still
number two you don't want to listen to
me the only way I would do it is if you
listen to me to the tee about take your
[__] stupid and somewhere else cuz I
don't need you because you're not
waiting you know you know you're wasting
my time and most importantly you're
wasting your own time yeah because
you're not even an ego bar yeah well you
can accept what the [__] mentality
you're too stupid so I don't want those
people we couldn't worry how to fix it
but you don't even know what you're
doing yes yes so it's kind of weird how
me Josh even Brody he was kind of
coaching yeah he was coaching Brody to
be crazy it like Jonah probably you
gotta be big Evan but him sound really
that one like that you gotta be bigger
with that joke
the joke is not gonna work unless it's
bigger well if he does it quiet right
that's what it was he was worried about
right he was funny I mean you're always
gonna be a little worried about like if
he's doing it quiet you're like it's not
it's like have you seen Joker no I'll
never see it again but it's great it's a
it's similar with school describe it
it's great that was uncomfortable most
of the movie and it's great that's why
it's great it's great well comfortable
that mother now the boy needs I hope
he's got a team of therapists because
you can't go to somewhere he thought he
went without bad stuff happening to you
when you were in your life the way he
went to some places we were just like oh
it's bad it's an artist it's like it's
just like we know there's some people
that listen when you watch modern family
yeah any other show on television you're
watching scrubs yeah Jennifer Aniston
was said the best actors in this town
over there and see there's a little
theater that there is in this [__]
town which kind of blows to him
disrespecting anybody but when you go to
these acting classes and [__]
knowing that like I always play myself
oh yeah I'm not an act
by myself I got the soprano movie I can
act sad when I'm yeah yeah important
lesson yeah I could never be the penguin
now I can never be very much yes yes
that's yes but there's people out there
that that's the gift of acting I realize
the guy that played the brother in the
fighter yes it's always a crackhead he's
tops in my book the black guy from
Lawrence whatever his name is Lawrence
Fishburne
yeah tops tops go watch him and what's
guests up to movies aren't what's his
name the guy have you ever seen Ghost
Dog you've never seen Ghost Dog that who
was it
Oh and what if I say how I know it's
Forest Whitaker Jim Jarmusch he's like a
samurai and hit by Queens or something
like that we a a Jim he's another good
actor this there's really actors you
know what you get self there's yeah I
watch it oh yeah real actors out there
and there's these guys that just did
just they just think they're actors yeah
they'll talk to you about all this
stanislavski's [__] but then I'll acting
I could talk all this Nastase [__] you
want all [__] day doesn't make me a
[__] actor now I know you're when
you're around an actor a real actor and
they see out cut and your whole body
goes what the [__] was that
that's a real actor and when you're
shooting ten feet from him like they
made you step out from the scene okay
you're not in the scene just one minute
you're not in this scene the cameras not
gonna cover you so step out and you see
the guy doing you're like holy [__]
that's acting that happens very rarely
with me when you're just like next to
somebody no oh whoa there's not many
people like that there's what you're
saying no there's not many people Brad
Pitt in the baseball movie brilliant
yeah he's [__] brilliant I went to
see whatever the [__] of malicious
Melissa
Maleficent with my daughter and my wife
last week where she's flying ourselves
Angelina Jolie yeah which is a witch
yeah yeah pretty much but
you have to remember that while I was
watching her I'm like no I know why she
gets oh god yeah okay when I watch
[__] Oh Scientology captain
Scientology Tom Cruise Tom Cruise
without a doubt he's everybody loved him
with all my heart first of all I love
Tom Cruise with all my yes do not even
think about it
watch collateral watch for novice guy uh
with all the sky it's awesome i laterals
when my favorite Mako and the [__] bar oh
shoot he gets into a military position
to start shooting they shoots the guy in
the heart I love middle I should there's
just certain people that you watching
Tropic Thunder when he comes like that
maybe though turn that off you don't
like some of the tropes are pretty funny
in it though people of this some movies
that just disrespect my what did you not
like about now I'm fast first ten
minutes just in yeah you only take a
little movie that you'll never hear me
talk about yeah everybody else like the
one with the dude a little bow ski you
know what I could I'm done I'm
indifferent about that as he so I'm very
indifferent ten minutes I had to turn it
off I just didn't buy there's a lot of
stuff I don't buy I don't know why I
don't buy it
I watched it but I was like I said I
like the star is born with Bradley
Cooper and Lady Gaga I'm one of those
[__] now I might not like something
for the weirdest reason there's just
something about if the movies too
popular and ten people who I think a has
always come up to me and tell me how
good the movie is I won't go watch the
movie out of spite
I'll do that with music if dollar say
yeah and then years later vectors I
stood on that when I was a kid and
tickets are $7 I used to I had to send
something to reel with me I didn't know
where the [__] it was
yeah I couldn't tap into the the thing
so I said send them one of our East
things
I'm the amazing racist thing oh oh oh
okay that's a holy the movies you don't
go see ya the movies I don't listen like
when I was a kid like there was too much
outside of I when I was when I was like
78 well it was samurai Night Fever no
well I was too many goofy kid that
didn't like watch them well I saw and I
saw mr. bell I'm supposed to laugh that
wasn't it's so funny last two weeks or
something you know so for some reason
cellular because I'm a thirty at night
now put on four white five minutes I'm
like this is just god-awful but this has
been America's comedy yeah for
twenty-something is they gauge comedy
from this 45 years you know 45 yeah I've
never the [__] it is and for me it's
never done nothing like a lot of things
like the end I that watch trains planes
and automobiles is on the last point
minutes almost canceled my spot
adjustable yeah like when that movies on
it's an acting class for me there's so
many things that I enjoy that like I
know what to see have a talk do you want
me to tell you the reason it yeah for
three hundred million dollars I get a
[__] to shoot a [__] movie that's
[__] and blind if I give somebody
300 million dollars it's like of me
giving the Yankees three hundred million
dollars and tell him to go out and get
pitching they're gonna be the best team
in baseball twenty years ago when I was
a kid I could always go to the Yankees
about paying off a World Series yeah
when you watch a team like the Nationals
and you see a mixture of old guys with a
mixture new guys they put something
special together
yes so I could either you know for watch
the A's play every year right yeah when
you tell me you know
oh well James Cameron's a genius he made
this movie he also had six hundred
million dollars okay so what the [__]
are you talking and the story I've been
you very simple top did you [__] it up I
see you so because of that I won't go
watch a movie I have different things
for different you know the let the
question on everybody's mind the last
week and I
see is all right now is Joey when are
you going to the weed cafe listen to me
and I wasn't me good if there's ten big
black guys with and big dicks and me
having to go into that week cafe in
Hollywood outstanding the line and take
the 10 big black dicks smoking dope
since I was 12 now just I mean I don't
need to know him it's a [__] you church
people who have heard about this cafe
and interested in that please stop
listening because if I catch in there
you're getting your stripes taken from
you have to pay a cover we're the church
we don't go we don't go to places to
make believe we get high we get high we
get high to get high you don't have to
go to a cafe in LA and sit around with
other people oh my god this is so cool
I wouldn't like the kid who told me
today the guy who told me today they
came up to me in 9/15 when I was hitting
the bag kickboxing today I went to kick
boxing I was kicking the bag he said hey
man have you been there
and well I looked at him and gave him my
answer he's like you should have seen
his face like I'm thinking to call him
apologize I didn't name this ID winded
everything he had because he's older he
should know better if a 20 year old
comes up to me and go have you been to
the weed cafe in Hollywood I get it
you're a [__] [__] but if a 50 year
old kid comes up to me and says have you
been to the weed cafe and how you would
how go a get it together that's what I
thought he you should have seen the look
I feel terrible I'm the calm today
I gotta get a number from a girl in
kickboxing call and apologize
I don't think all those things I'm
[__] had me smoking those as I was 12
well what I need to do a week cafe to
prove to you there was a cool there was
a dab lounge for a while and this is
Studio C or somewhere around there that
they did shows in it was cool because
you go in this head shop and then there
was like a like bookshelf and he pulled
the bookshelf open and then there's a
back hallway and there was like a club
it was like a lot of like the early I
think like money people in dabs would go
back there and then they'd throw you
dabs and so
it has like six months so lucam you know
that place closed yeah and there was a
dispensary on Vineland that had comedy
for a while but it uh I think I think
was before the recreational stuff and
they kept it open as long as they could
but that place is gone yeah I know
you're doing really well I know you
decided one of my agents
yeah I like that I know you with a dear
friend of mine that's a manager he's the
best what do you got going up yeah well
I'm I've been doing stuff with the
Squidbillies that show on Adult Swim I
got a bunch of voices on that now and
then which is just making fun of people
I went to high school with or grew up
around mostly grew up around we're known
with the high school it and then didn't
stand up a lot that's my bread and
butter I like stand up so much you chew
a lot I try to but you know I got two
kids now so it's that thing you're like
what ten I have a ten-year-old and then
a nine month old it's their two boys
they both look just like me it's great
and I don't I mean I jerk about the
headache of it but I loved every second
of it and I think that that's and then I
like you said like if I was younger in
my career it would be a problem but I've
I must just established enough I can
make enough money if I want to and then
do it the way I want to my wife does
well enough that we're okay financially
so it's just I don't I like to be gone
but I like to be at home which is a new
thing do you know what I mean you know
it's weird how Led Zepplin without free
year whole year they love all the guns
and roses all in all the big bands in
the semanas you get put out there for a
year year and a half and that's great
yeah you know that's great I'm sure you
put away a lot of money once you have
the children you know I feel that it's
either pay me now or pay me later
situation if you don't give them the
attention now someday when they're 16
it's going to [__] start to haunt you
because you were never there
four five yeah you know I've said before
I've adjusted my schedule for the house
I work six days on you month
yeah I can't keep me in pork chops you
know I'm saying I don't know what else
well well that's
it's just doing what around the house I
do a podcast of my daughter on Tuesdays
tonight I'm in with a you know no
tonight employ in New Jersey you know I
try to spend the sunday is the Lord's
Day in my house it's y'all eat dinner at
6:00 I take it right back to the
beginning there's no restaurant yeah
family home that's it when we will [__]
that's chick-fil-a style Papa don't want
to work on Sunday night lately I've been
going to the store on Sunday nights and
I feel guilty but it's such a great
night to go down there because there's
nobody there that's the best night we
walk through the [__] halls like
there's no there's no it's so sad don't
even look for a friend you can't find
the ghost even the ghosts down there
take off on Sunday you know so that's
the best thing that's my favorite day in
the club Sunday when you're traveling on
the road I mean I don't do them many
because I could that's a you know I want
to get back I try to take the earliest
fly back to get back to my son he's 10
you know like that's a day off from
school it's like the first flight you
ever [__] out Oh without a doubt but
like I think back in like those are the
best days there's Sunday nights of the
club when it's like you know 40 people
and your [__] you're not doing your act
you're doing a version of your act well
by Sunday nights in the old days yes
that said what I'm talking want to do
another joke after Sam no especially you
had three shows by the third show you're
confused you don't even know what joke
it told if you told it before if you
didn't say we don't know what I'm
talking about I bring that oh we're done
three [__] are you talking about the car
you don't even know horrible you got
said that act and it's three [__]
shows and you that you're opening for
Rogen or Pablo or [__] Gabriel and by
the third show you have no idea you're
up there going
did I say this already and then your
[__] sometimes you do dog a couple times
in Miami people like you said that
already I'm like that's the worst place
that can happen to and then you do
Sunday you wake up you're tired your
girlfriend's on the phone I wish you
were here we're all gonna go to the
beach and you're like great
you mean for work oh yeah I'm a [__]
hole [__] hole in the hotel oh by the
way that great sandwich place across
from the hotel is now closed
yeah Sunday so now everything changes
you've been used and now you're tired
you've been there all week and now
you're instead of walking one block up
the corner you gotta walk for for
something you don't want to eat because
it's the other thing that's [__] open
and then you're back in your room but
it's 1:00 in the afternoon and then show
that's a seven that's the work and
there's no football there's golf you
know I did that's why Sunday I got our
seven years thousand two thousand one I
was already like Joe Rogan we can't work
something what do you tell them it's
painful
little by little I went away with him
one day I go John not doing it you have
time not done coming home Sunday let
already stay with you and we had taunted
disagreements in today hey nobody works
Sundays on my book and if you do god
bless you
I don't have nothing against you I just
when you listen but again I decided this
in 2001 I was also doing comedy ten
years yeah
and for two years I'd follow a line
dancing class on Sunday is it [__]
eight o'clock in Denver I had her in
mind or you walk in at 4:00 you get
chicken strips as that's all you can eat
and then the club is packed and you're
like what [__] is the club packing
around oh there's three guys from
General Hospital talking like what are
they doing they just talk like and it
sold out yeah there's just women's
that was the first thing where I was
like I don't we made it I made a mistake
here there was a lot in those days they
used to it was that [__] idiot widget
whatever his [__] name is hatchet
scratches screech screech yes really
a screech and 8:09 soap opera guy yes
that was the [__] college tour that
would either let everyone had terrible
stories about screech he would come like
they're like oh he can't work here
anymore
like damn her so fast he stabbed a guy
he said it's uh it's interesting you're
the first guy I've ever heard say that
Sunday was a fun day for you like this
the show is fun okay because it didn't
matter then it was like and then you got
to do more time you weren't like worried
about not getting hired again right okay
that's what I meant like from a stand-up
perspective if that makes sense like
he's right about every other part of it
but that as a stand-up you were just
like this is fun I'm gonna try some
stuff that I knew I couldn't do all week
and then there's like four servers I got
to know kind of good that are here and
we've been drinking so this is kind of
fun I was like that it was loose when it
wasn't your show that last Sunday oh my
god that was tremendously yeah you had
you can't through that day right yeah
day was a [__] that's why I decided I
decided like 2001-2002 in Dallas it hit
me I was like Sunday's are not made I've
worked it up Sunday people get status
and then I started tickling around with
it and once a long is yard came out I
had enough clout to go poppin awesome
and that was it but I don't think a lot
of clubs do Sundays at all and if they
do good they don't they don't get greedy
[__] yeah they're gonna work a Sunday
for no [__] reason to give away 40
tickets that's what I don't wear your
[__] staff cut the [__] Sunday cut
it like if it's somebody drawing yeah
especially in cities like Denver Kansas
City Miami where it's football you can
during those 17 weeks close on Sunday
you can cuz all I'm gonna get is the
Reaper the bottom the bottom of the
barrel Boston so well
you want to do a show Sunday they have
the Red Sox are in the playoffs and the
New England Patriots a home do you know
you're gonna get you're gonna get the
dregs of the [__] those who were lost
to come to your [__] show go home go
the [__] home
it doesn't make any I did a show on
Halloween one time I got [__] you know
who it was in Slade's Club in Beaumont
okay and I remember being like dude he's
like I thought more people would show up
and I was like people never come this is
the dumbest thing in the world I just I
didn't think you wanna see me I'm gonna
go out Tuesday I think and maybe
Saturday next week so Wednesday and
Thursday next week a debt its doubled my
Thursday night yeah and it's All Saints
Day I'm [__] Friday Saturday I'm
Souls Day and then All Saints Day of the
second yeah Saturday will be fun yeah
it'll be fun but most Halloween parties
are this weekend oh this weekend
see I don't I've never been a dress-up
me neither I want to dress up again I
rather get [__] by the ten black blues
than this if I want to be someone else
always be someone else for the day I
started getting up in that dress I think
after like nine I just put a towel on
yeah you're just like this isn't candy
thing yeah this shy stewardess said oh
well that was nineteen I dressed up like
an abortion that's what I in a quaalude
passed out that [__] never got for the
thing that was it I never dressed up I
guess I don't like nothing that [__] you
don't like coilette I love quaaludes do
you think there's something still around
someone's bringing this up the other day
um I'm sure that listen man I think I
know a couple I know chemist that said
whatever gender they are I'm not gonna
repeat it yes ami wants that they can
make cocaine if they wanted there's
chemical properties yeah so if you went
back and looked to see what I was in a
quaalude I'm sure somebody's making some
concoctions I'm very fond chemist yeah
and if you want me to tell you the truth
the truth is that first time I did
in ecstasy I thought it was somebody who
was working on a quaalude made a mistake
oh really
do you know wasn't like it was cousins
to quaalude in a way ah you for it
euphoric and soft
you know don't drink too much on it cuz
it might take you to a different level
so you don't want to drink on it either
right
I don't know I don't know I wasn't a big
ecstasy guy I think I'd the next scene
would be three times I did the MDMA [__]
that you drink really see I'm never I
missed a lot of those that fills me up I
was at the store one night pill I never
[__] with pills and I think that I
skipped a lot of those I [__] the
pills when I first became an open mic I
liked because I had sleep problem ah and
now instead I used the edibles
see I was weed I was tall weed was so
bad growing up and then when I tried it
it like helped so much stuff yeah I was
like those oh oh this is great so it
helps so much stuff amazing we keep our
powder dry yeah that's a weed does for
me to keeps my powder job before I stab
a [__] I smoke a joint it's sad
and give a call a girl at four in the
morning
not anymore him you better at the club
at two when she thought he's gonna suck
you think I have been in that situation
she's like well I come home but I've
been burning my friend Lucy with me
because I don't want nothing to happen
he like hold on let me call you back and
then you're bang were not real good at
all so she calls my there's a camera
around the corner you like oh [__] yes
yes you know what you just eliminated a
thousand dilemmas by me banging one out
not worrying about you and your friend
and now your friends chat chubby and she
don't want to stay cuz she don't like
you know you don't have hummus
whatever the [__] yeah you have to keep
her busy yeah that's it one snake corn
they gotta bring a friend one of the
chants are you breaking me away from
your [__] friend zero unless you
leave her a cheeseburger and you go in
and say come here for a second I will
show you my dick so it's like it's just
those types still in Vegas a gamble yeah
right I'm gonna give a [__] gamble
you like you know what I don't want to
do this [__] no more that's like when
they gave John Mayer [__] cuz
Roland so a couple years ago he was like
yeah sometimes I got a jerk-off in the
bathroom at like public places he's like
it saves me a lot of trouble and they
gave him [__] for that I was like that's
the smartest thing I've ever heard
I think that's you should tell young
boys that like when they're going into
college be like hey just go into that
stall and jerk off and treat it like
you're taking a [__] or something and
then come out and then see if you still
want to do that like how much that would
save especially with phones analogies
yeah yeah oh god yeah yeah that's how
mostly I watch porn is on my phone
because I have kids and it's in my
[__] room I never watch spoiling my
phone
really that's thing that's not Watson
come on send me a picture several more
when Billy Wayne it was a pleasure to
[__] see yes it's a pleasure we both
came from the same mentor yeah we did
God rest his soul
wherever he is and yeah even though you
lived in town I'm I had no [__] late
I don't I need to get into this store
more but do you perform anywhere locally
yeah I do the improv I do that uh the
dynasty typewriter oh that's great it is
a great little room yes uh there's no
parking that's the nightmare where's
your website a bwd tor.com if you just
google billy wind davis all that [__]
comes up that's the easiest way I've got
Instagram Twitter all that but all my
dates are in bwd tor.com I'm going to
Seattle next week
the parla know that closed they closed
because my friend Rick Taylor up in the
little room on Capitol Hill called Club
comedy it's great it's next to tower
restaurant it's fantastic
don't be up there be [__] great to
see it's so good to see looking at you
I'm seeing all the memories and last we
have oh I passed the I wanted to bring
this up because eat Ralphie when I
really met you like we've met like it
were talked about in Florida but after I
was getting my divorce and it was like
very clear this was happening Ralphie's
like I gotta take you somewhere homes in
LA we went to this all-you-can-eat sushi
place on Ventura and you just lay
down science is the only way I could
describe it that's like some of the
stuff didn't happen but some of it
happened in a way that I was like I
remember when it's happening made me
laugh instead of like you know being my
father sucks in his sad it was just like
oh yeah Coco said it was gonna happen
during the divorce yeah is that stuff
like you gave me this thing like it was
entertaining but I remember you were
telling me some of it I was like nah you
know what I mean like a dummy where
you're just like you don't understand
and I it's I've actually used that the
way I describe it is when you're getting
a divorce you're gonna start having
emotions you didn't know existed about
things it will just blow your mind so
you just like you have to be aware
that's happened that's gonna happen and
you were just you gave me these though
like beats about some things and about
the human condition and about human
nature that when you're in your 20s you
don't want to accept that's why you keep
making some of those mistakes do you
know I mean and you just it made me my I
was like I've been there well that was
it - like there's just like there's like
you really there smells you're gonna
have and I was like oh I told you
something that cut me through this soul
I tell everybody that anything that cuts
me yeah I pass it to people because I'm
tough and if it cut me it's gonna [__]
you up yeah well I tell you some if it
[__] cut me it's gonna [__] you up
you know like and if it cut me at the
age and the amount that it did after
what I've gone through and if you
haven't gone through anything before
that this is gonna [__] you up
psychologic yeah the point where you
might become the joker yeah cuz I was
very close I don't know what the joke is
about I don't care I'm gonna see it
eventually I know it's something to do
with killing and I was six months from
becoming the Joker and I've been in ten
different situations and there's only
one situation that took me to that place
divorce yeah it's the force will take
you to that place when somebody's going
through a divorce I read something years
ago the statistics of men hanging them
and women and this is something that's
harder than a death of a family member
at some times and I tell people the
number one rule well I see a guy come
over to me and he's married he's talking
to a girl he's got I go before you gonna
[__] that chicken the smell of your kids
with some other man's Cologne on when
you bend over the smell of she's gonna
break you like you've never been broken
before I could stand you up and kick in
the nuts ten times and then take bend
over and kiss your daughter and when you
smell that [__] baklava yeah that
whatever the [__] they have on and you
straighten back up your whole life
changes like you're like I blew it this
bad that somebody else is being a parent
to my child well mine was different but
it prepared me for that it don't have to
because and also it's that just that
illuminating when I don't think human
beings talk about it's like that sense
of smell how nostalgic it is just like
where it takes you instantly and how
people know about that and they
manipulate that all the time like I was
up in Eugene Reese this past weekend
best weed in the world my friend Mike
grows the weight up there he was telling
me the terpenes you know that's all they
talk about is his smell in this man he
was mentioning it to his mom he's
talking about she worked at Campbell's
soup she's like oh we know all about
terpenes that's when we're making the v8
thing we just say we put fake terpenes
in it so it tastes more like the fruit
but we use cheaper fruit and that was
just crackly she cracks me up this is
like oh so we know like that's that
they're manipulating that all the time
too so we're [__]
might as well enjoy it enjoy you bad
[__] do not forget November 7th
at the Motor City casino I think there's
like four tickets left and I got the
Omaha funnybone the Colleen telling her
oh that's my girl 8th and 9th
at all volleyball in Columbus and then
Omaha Omaha and then November 28th and
29th The Improv in Miami the night after
Thanksgiving I am I got fried to shows
Friday to Saturday and Saturday lates
already sold out
don't come crime here attend Cubans [__]
that you didn't get tickets because the
welfare check them get there get your
tickets now before we call this a [__]
day a few little word from our sponsors
number one it's over by the [__]
[__] money season is here forget
about football season it's my bookie
Dodd AG if you're trying to bet on
whatever and I found World Series and
then man they got it they're running a
super contest I don't know how to enter
you pick five [__] teams to
cover against the spread and you rack up
points you get the most points you win
$100,000 it's that easy
they just revamped their site and it's
looking [__] tremendous take a look
if you haven't already but do me a favor
this is how we're getting this party
started tomorrow on Instagram I'm gonna
release the [__] video but today
today it's Thursday morning what the
[__] it came out this morning I didn't
give out any pics but I'm gonna teach
you how to make some [__] bets and
how to make money alright so go to my
go-to man flavors world right now but
before you do that do me a favor double
your first deposit right now by using
promo code Church to get 100 percent
bonus on your initial deposit up to
$1,000 visit my bookie dot AG today
that's my bookie my bo o ki e dot AG and
don't forget to use the promo code
Church grab a pen [__] CH you are
CH when creating your account to claim
the bonus very important listen it's
Halloween you don't want to show up with
your dick looking like The Wolfman okay
nobody every woman wants to get dressed
up with stockings and [__] everybody's
in the mood to suck dick and eat [__]
I'm sure every woman in America right
now is doing a little [__] douchey
douche with carrots or whatever the [__]
they do and you sit there
that soap is gonna work no you gotta
trim the whole [__] thing okay uncle
Joey's here to tell you [__] him this
Halloween keep the cobwebs out of your
[__] [__] area clean the [__]
bumpers thick before she sucks that
tailpipe listen my friends over at
manscape
they created a tool that you need to
shave your balls and the area around the
[__] death stick it's called a lawn
mower 2.0 for a reason they threw a 21.0
away go [__] yourself send that to
somebody with a missing foot and they
upgraded that trimmer with skin safe
technology okay if you look at my video
on Monday I have shaved my balls for you
people so go to med flame as well that's
Monday and I'm gonna show you the toilet
paper the toilet bowl filled with uncle
Joey a little pubic and you can see the
little pubic ends because I've been
keeping up and ever since I've been with
manscape I've been [__] shaving
around the dick area in the ball area
for months now I'm like a savage down
there too bad I got nobody to suck it
you know I'm saying who wants a suck a
56 year old dick you look what happened
- Harvey's victims Plus let me tell you
something nobody wants a suck on old
dicks of you over 40 make sure you get
manscape today cuz they'll take away
that gray [__] older smell you got
down on your dick trust me I've washed
with [__] plenty of things even Irish
Spring you screwed you scratch around
your dick with that dry hair cuz when
was the last time you condition your
ball head never you just leave it there
to look like remember Kerry's mother in
that movie Carrie well mother's hair
looks like that's what your pubic hair
looks like but it's over manscape got
your dick looking [__] shiny listen
if this is the first time you consider
manscape and they got the deal for you
it's called the perfect package it comes
with a lawnmower and a safety razor plus
the crop Reserve especially formulated
deodorant for your balls so it'll stink
like your ass oh and the Reviver a
spritz that tones up your nuts and
refreshes your junk to keep it cool like
me I'm 56 my nuts are wrinkled there
looking like a Mexicans neck like
they're all [__] fat like one of
those one of those pug dogs with the
[__] neck that's what Nana I put a
little
revival on their the balls were looking
like two [__] globes you can even see
Europeans and I still got leave another
Thursday more than what I'm about to get
on the plane anyway get the perfect
package your pouch will be powdered and
your pole will be perfect what the [__]
are you waiting for listen the church
family gets 20% off your first order
when you use promo code Church CH you
are CH at manscape calm and if you order
the perfect package don't throw in a
free [__] travel bag when you
use code Church there's a zipper in it
I'm not gonna tell you what you can put
in there but use your imagination
that's manscape calm use promo code
church for 20% off your first order and
keep your balls clean the church is also
brought to you by let me ask you a
question you've heard us talk about
hymns and how they're helping guys look
their best whether its erections whether
it's hair loss if you haven't yet it's
time to see what they're about do me a
favor go to for hints calm your like
Joey why why cuz it's one stop shop for
hair loss skin court skincare and sexual
wellness for men is that hairline slowly
starting to move backwards take a look
in the mirror real quick right you don't
look like [__] he used to you like
Bela Lugosi now any bald spots yet yeah
you got a bald spot just like me the
best way to prevent more hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have some it's time to get a handle on
these precious locks I asked you you
want a bald spot to pop up on your
hairline or your head line to recede
what do you do what I want to do
something about it first what do you
want to do tell me you want to sit down
like a Mook the Lord or you want to look
like you [__] join Led Zeppelin why
do guys turn to with solutions for
nothing when they don't do nothing they
don't do nothing you could turn to
medicine in science that's why for hymns
is here what we're gonna do is this
isn't the same don't snake oil pills a
gas station they send over this is
prescription solutions backed by science
no more awkward doctor visits you know
in all long pharmacy knives
forums connects you with a real doctor
online which you can save hours with
completely confidential and it's
discrete you answer a few questions the
doctor reviews it they determine what's
right for you they prescribe medication
for either hair loss edie and they ship
it right to your [__] door okay
nobody knows nothing and you have rings
so you seeking somebody steals your
viagra if you see the old man down the
corner with a [__] coupe to bud you
know he stole your viagra anyway get the
hair loss treatment everybody's talking
about it's featured in GQ Men's Health
Esquire and Playboy order now the church
family gets started with the hims
complete Hecate for five dollars a week
five hours five hours today right now
while supplies last and subject the
doctor's approval see website for full
details and safety information
you know this Uncle Joe is telling you
this could cost you hundreds of [__]
dollars
you understand me I'm gonna hook you up
for five hours gonna for hims dot-com
slash Joey again that's for hims calm
slash Joey I want to thank for hymns I
want to thank manscape I wanna thank my
bookie I want to thank you [__]
for always being family one thing Billy
Wayne I want to thank the [__]
for putting this whole thing together
and I'll see you [__] next
Thursday in Detroit and next Friday and
Saturday no behind not we'll see you
Tuesday morning tip-top Magoo ready to
[__] go I love you guys
Thank You Billy Wayne this is another
[__] [__] have a great
weekend stay black bye that's it